okay so Donald Trump brought a Twitter
CEO Jack Dorsey into the Oval Office and
confronted him not about anything
important just about how Trump doesn't
like that he lost some of his fake
followers that Twitter determined to be
BOTS and trolls there are some really
serious things that anybody with an
ounce of knowledge and an ounce of
interest could actually talk about with
Jack Dorsey I would love to have Jack
Dorsey on the program and we could talk
about the issue of self-reinforcing
feedback loops that create echo chambers
on Twitter we could talk about the
growing body of scholarship on how
damaging early social media use is to
children and adults and see what he
thinks
Twitter's role in mitigating that should
be if any we could talk about societal
problems that a platform of Twitter size
could potentially help with whether it's
suicide prevention or bullying I mean
almost anything would be more
interesting and relevant to discuss with
Jack Dorsey than Twitter's policy of
every once in a while clearing out fake
followers and and BOTS and in particular
for the President of the United States
you would hope that he would talk to
Jack Dorsey about more important things
but Donald Trump brought Jack Dorsey
Twitter CEO into the Oval Office
and spent a bunch of time complaining
about the fact that he lost followers on
Twitter
and it's really one of those sir this is
a Burger King drive-thru sort of moments
where Jack Dorsey for his part did the
right thing and said Oh Trump these
these were BOTS and fake followers and
Trump genuinely seems to believe that
when he loses followers on Twitter
he's losing them because of political
bias that Twitter is haphazardly just
like the leading conservative accounts
that it's some kind of anti Trump
Twitter bias or that there are general
purges going on of conservative and
right-wing ideology and everybody in the
room that has spoken about this said
Trump just was fixated on this issue of
the followers that he had lost and
Dorsey did the best he could to explain
to Trump who does have a limited ability
to understand
stuff that every once in a while Twitter
purges accounts that they determined to
be fake accounts or bought accounts that
when this was done Jack Dorsey lost
followers on Twitter and that you sort
of lose Twitter of followers in
proportion to the number that you have
if you have 50 million followers
when invalid fake and bought accounts
are removed it stands to reason that you
will lose more followers than someone
who has only a hundred thousand
followers just by sort of simple math
and again this is not really primarily
about Twitter although there is a lot
about Twitter to talk about it's once
again Donald Trump's obsession despite
being President of the United States
with another equivalent or proxy to an
irrelevant penis size contest we've
heard multiple times now that Trump has
complained to people around him that
Obama had more Twitter followers than
Trump and still does Obama has like
fifty million more Twitter followers
than Trump who cares and that Trump is
bothered by this because Trump sees
himself at being much much better on
Twitter and much better at Twitter than
his former President Barack Obama now it
is true that Obama really does have way
way way more followers on Twitter than
Donald Trump has but for a 70 something
year-old man to be obsessed with this
this particularly when you're President
of the United States can you imagine
being this degree of the sort of
petulant child and so ignorant that you
get the CEO of Twitter into the Oval
Office and you complain to him about
your followers you can have very serious
criticisms of the entire appearance on
the Joe Rogan program by Jack Dorsey
particularly the first appearance and
you can argue Joe should have been
better prepared which Joe ultimately
admitted you can even criticize the
second appearance of Jack Dorsey on the
Joe Rogan program where Jack came with
like a Twitter lawyer and Tim Poole was
they're asking sort of antagonistic
questions of Jack Dorsey you can
complain about all of that stuff but
they were at least attempting to be
serious discussions about issues
relevant to social media
the public square' free-speech
censorship and large platforms the
vanity of Trump wanting to look strong
the vanity of wanting to be pictured in
the Oval Office the vanity of wanting to
have a lot of Twitter followers that's
all that this is about it's all it's
ever been about and people could do so
much good with access to the likes of
those like Jack Dorsey in those
positions of power and Trump is doing
none of it he's just berating CEOs about
the number of followers he has it's
shameful it's embarrassing and at this
point it's completely expected because
it's what we've grown to just expect for
the President of the United States based
on his actions and the world continues
to laugh at us